I also am very frustrated with moments
where it seems like an action is being
taken either because the writer is being
lazy or the character is being stupid
does comedy have the same plot structure
as drama
most of the time
The Arc of a comic story is this
the hero goes through an arc of change
from denial to acceptance of the theme
the thing he has to fix and he is
rewarded with community
uh I'm thinking about the movie Liar
Liar Jim Carrey is a pathological liar
he needs to learn to tell the truth so
he undergoes an arc of change from
denial to acceptance he goes from
thinking lying is good to telling the
truth is good and he's rewarded with a
good relationship with his son so he's
rewarded with Community if you think
about every movie you've ever seen with
the word wedding in the title
The Arc is always the same Heroes go
from denial to acceptance of the thing
they need to change in order to win true
love then they were rewarded with true
love they're rewarded with entrance into
community
in its most profound expression which is
couple Hood in the eyes of the tribe
that's kind of how we value community at
the utmost
the difference between comedy and
tragedy specifically in comedy the hero
learns the lesson of the theme and is
rewarded with community in tragedy the
hero never learns the lesson of the
theme and is punished with
Exile or death
right now I'm thinking about God how
many times have I said right now I'm
thinking about when I watch this video
back I will knock myself in ahead for
having said right now I'm thinking about
so many times examples are great though
thank you let's consider The Great
Gatsby Gatsby never learns that his path
to glory is not the one that he thinks
it is and he's
devastated in the end or King Lear
classic tragedy of King lyric look leer
you only have to do one thing accept
your daughter's love if you do that all
will be well no I'm a dumbass I'm
stubborn I cannot accept her Love
Therefore I must die in the wilderness
blind insane and alone
that's what happens when you don't learn
the lesson so what's the difference
between comedy and drama
well between the difference between
comedy and tragedy is clearly in comedy
the hero learns the lesson in tragedy
the hero never learns the lesson drama
can kind of end up both ways you can
reach a space where the characters have
achieved understanding
but still get a bad outcome
that's problematic for audiences I'll
give you a great example the movie
Thelma and Louise these characters need
to undergo transformation one needs to
have a authentic bond with another human
being that's Thelma and one needs to set
herself free from her abusive
relationship that's Louise I think I
have it right if it's not that it's
exactly the other way around they go on
a journey together they achieve their
outcome but the way they achieve the
outcome
in in achieving the outcome that across
the line that Society will not allow
they kill they murder and so they have
to pay the ultimate price and at the end
of the movie in the original screenplay
I've read it it looks like this
they fly off the cliff sorry spoiler
alert they fly off the cliff and crash
and die the end when they tested that
ending in front of audiences the
audiences hated it because they love
Thelma and Louise they don't want to see
the Thelma and Louise die they want a
happy ending the story will not allow a
happy ending so the filmmaker very
cleverly creates the expectation of a
happy ending or at least the suspension
of the bad ending we now see Thelma and
Louise taking off and Freeze Frame
and we know yeah they're probably going
to die but in this moment we can imagine
that they live in eternity and they got
their happy ending exact same ending as
Butch Cassidy and Sundance Kid where
butcher Butch and Sundance by the way if
you haven't seen that class go see that
Butch and Sundance they have their backs
to the wall they must die and they run
out with guns blazing and they're shot
dead but it's Freeze Frame so we never
see them die they live on an eternity
that's how you
bring a character to a tragic but not
unhappy ending what are some of your pet
peeves when it comes to plot
I was watching a movie last night called
narvik it's a
no no no I got a better example I
recently read for the first time in my
life Treasure Island
uh Robert Louis Stevenson's classic tale
of pirates and piracy I didn't realize
how many of our pirate tropes come from
that novel but the plot was very
unsatisfying to me my pet peeve was I
was ahead of the narrator I knew what
was going to happen even though the
narrator was trying to fool me I could
see several steps ahead so that's a pet
peeve for me when the narrative is not
sufficiently sophisticated that I don't
know what's happening
when that I that I know too easily
what's happening that there's not an
interesting puzzle for me to solve
interestingly I decided I'm going to cut
Robert Lewis even Stevenson a little
slack because when he wrote those plot
twists they were brand new nobody had
ever contemplated a move like that in a
novel before so and and the 10 year old
boys who encounter it they've never
experienced it it's spellbinding to them
it's a legitimate move we go back to the
big fat middle maybe I'm not the Right
audience for that book
a pet peeve of mine in storytelling is
storytelling that's clumsy
unsophisticated makes it too easy for me
to problem solve I also am very
frustrated with moments where it seems
like an action is being taken either
because the writer is being lazy or the
character is being stupid I find those
are places where I check out of a story
if I feel like I'm reading something I
say to the writer man you could have
done better than that that's just yeah
that's it that's only an okay choice I
expected better than you than that of
you or more profoundly if the writer
gives the character a choice that
doesn't make sense according to my
understanding of the character I'm not
having that I I will not tolerate
um
I won't root for a hero who doesn't know
enough to act in his own self-interest
there's a great example but I'm not sure
if I can share it because it has to do
with Avatar 2 the way of water there's a
moment in Avatar 2.
the hero has has taken his family to
safety they're safe
as long as they don't make any mistakes
the bad guys will never find them
they've achieved their mission trouble
is if if they've achieved their mission
that's where the movie ends it's not
very interesting and this is very early
in the movie relatively early
character makes a mistake character
reaches out to allies in the outer world
and unintentionally tips off the bad
guys where he is he gives him he gives
himself away
is is what happens and I say to myself I
leave this movie right here because you
just did something so manifestly not in
your self-interest either you did it
because you didn't care or you did it
because you didn't know and either way I
no longer like you I've checked out
emotionally I ran this by a friend of
mine and he said you were watching the
wrong movie
Avatar 2 the way of water isn't about
strategic choices it's about pretty
pictures and if you you'll give yourself
a better movie going experience if you
take if you meet it where it lives
so to speak and so I realized once again
I'm bringing my expectations to the
story I'm losing enjoyment because I'm
letting my expectations interfere with
the moment if I just let go of my
expectations and let the movie be
exactly what it is I'm going to have a
better time the real takeaway from this
is don't have pet peeves don't have them
at all don't have expectations and then
you won't be disappointed meet the
material where it is recognize it's not
a good movie or a bad movie it's just
the movie that it is
there's a great one that people argue
about all the time it was uh
the the
Disaster Artist James Franco's take on
that guy I don't even remember his name
but that guy made a movie that people
couldn't stand
the room that people couldn't stand but
other people found surprising value in
it the ones who couldn't stand it
couldn't stand it because it didn't
match the Norms they expected the ones
who had had value in it were the ones
who met it where it was well this is
this guy's expression he's got something
to say he's gone to some effort to say
it let's Embrace what he has to say
rather than rejecting it because it
doesn't fit our expectations
nevertheless writers keep your character
smart because audiences will leave
they're not as generous of spirit as you
would like them to believe be and
they'll leave if they feel like the
character is doing things that they
can't get behind